hello again I want to talk about why
apple cider vinegar works for weight
loss okay it really has nothing to do
with nutrition in the episode of vinegar
it has to do with the acetic acid okay
acetic acid lowers the output of insulin
it improves insulin resistance that's
amazing and it also decreases blood
sugars and improves the a1c which is the
average blood sugars for about three
months
so since insulin is the main hormone
that causes you to gain weight anything
that improves insulin will help you lose
weight I'll put some links down below to
give you more information on the
research behind it but very simple you
take a tablespoon of absolute vinegar
okay does it have to be Bragg's no it
can pretty much be any vinegar I mean I
like the organics better because of you
know no pesticides but just do one
tablespoon is all sort of integrate in a
glass of water I do a little more than 8
ounces I'll probably do 12 ounces one
tablespoon of lemon okay lemon also
helps blood sugars by the way now some
people put honey Tupelo Honey or raw
honey I do that unless it's for your
kids or you're not trying to lose weight
because there is that sugar there but
some people like to offset the taste but
instead just to stevia liquid stevia
lemon drops or just liquid stevia and
that will sweeten in a little bit and
that'll just make it a nice little lemon
drink okay next question is like when to
take it I like to do one in the morning
one in the evening some people do it
with their meals if they have a
digestive issue it's not a bad idea and
you can even add one one with a meal
just to improve your digestion or some
people even take one in the morning and
one in the evening an empty stomach it's
not a problem you can even take it
before bed all right so go ahead and
apply this and put your comments below